I'M TELLING YOU,
IT'S TOTALLY LEGAL.
THESE DOCTORS,
THEY'LL PRESCRIBE
MEDICAL MARIJUANA
TO ANYONE, MAN.
- WHAT DO I TELL THEM
I NEED IT FOR?
- IT DOESN'T MATTER.
THEY WANT TO GIVE YOU
A PRESCRIPTION.
IT'S HOW THEY GET PAID.
JUST MAKE SOMETHING UP.
- HEY, MR. WASHINGTON,
WELCOME.
- HEY, DOCTOR.
- ALL RIGHT, I'M GOING
TO ASK YOU A COUPLE QUESTIONS,
AND THEN WE'RE--
- AIDS.
- WHAT?
- AIDS?
AS IN, UH--
- AS IN I GOT IT, NEED LOTS
OF WEED TO GET RID OF IT.
- OH, OKAY, AIDS.
UM, WOW.
ALL RIGHT, ARE YOU SURE
YOU'RE NOT SUFFERING
FROM ANYTHING ELSE LIKE,
YOU KNOW, BACK PAIN?
- NOPE.
- ANXIETY?
- COOL AS A CUCUMBER.
- HOW ABOUT INSOMNIA?
- SLEEP LIKE A BABY...
WITH AIDS.
- OKAY, MR. WASHINGTON.
LET'S JUST SLOW YOUR ROLL
FOR A SECOND HERE.
IF YOU HAD AIDS,
THEN I WOULD HAVE TO VERIFY IT
BY SEEING TEST RESULTS.
WHEREAS IF YOU BACK PAIN
OR ANXIETY OR ANYTHING ELSE
THAT I CAN'T TEST FOR,
THEN I CAN GIVE YOU
THIS PRESCRIPTION
FOR CANNABIS RIGHT NOW.
- OH.
- UNDERSTAND?
- OH, I SEE, I GET IT.
- AWESOME.
- MY BAD.
- GOOD, GOOD, GOOD.
- OKAY, SO--
- LEPROSY.
- NO, NO.
BECAUSE IF YOU HAD LEPROSY,
I'D HAVE TO QUARANTINE YOU.
- OUCH.
- WHAT ARE YOU--NO.
OKAY, I SEE
YOUR FINGER'S FALLING OFF.
NO, DON'T DO THAT, THOUGH.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO WORK.
- SCURVY.
- NOPE.
- RICKETS.
- WHAT? NO.
- CONSUMPTION.
- NO, MR. WASHINGTON.
SOMETHING FROM
THIS CENTURY.
- SCHIZOPHRENIA.
[high pitched]
YOU DON'T HAVE SCHIZOPHRENIA.
YES, YOU DO.
- KEEP IT SIMPLE.
PLEASE.
WHAT THE HELL IS THAT?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT IS.
- THERE'S A FISH HOOK
IN MY LIP.
- JUST PICK SOMETHING
OFF THIS LIST.
- I CAN'T REACH IT.
- WHY NOT?
- PARALYZED.
- DOES YOUR FACE HURT,
MR. WASHINGTON?
- YEAH.
- THEN THIS SHOULD HELP.
[buzzer]